we get tj zoick this afternoon after a
late scratch by ross stripling tj gets
the ball for the second start of the
season his first one came against the
yankees and he pitched very effectively
so here's aaron hicks the first pitch of
the ball game is cut on and lifted into
center field kuching backing up a few
steps one pitch one out the yankees are
the only team in the majors that have
not scored a first inning run this year
so now that's the cue for judge they had
a home run right here
everybody's talking about it that one is
drilled to left field and that ball is
gone see ya they've got a first inning
run they have a one-nothing lead but
aaron judge i'd rather see you hit a
home run and go along with my scouting
report good job michael way to call it
a judgian blast
and as he rounds third
all rise
toward first drake will have to hustle
over there
it's bang bang tower peles to zoick and
gardner's retirement two-way
oh two pits
tj zwick boxes back after the home run
to judge gets the next two match but the
yankees have a one-nothing lead as we
head to the bottom of the first corey
kluber
cooper making his third start of the
year six in the third inning so far
with five walks he struck out eight with
the white sox he's four for 20 pitch his
cut out of this struck him out swinging
one man out bottom of the first a 2-2
grounded to third
rochelle makes the throw crossing in
front of him was beset first and third
two men out for biggie 1-2
swing and a miss
kluber gets bgo to get out of trouble
ground ball this should be too
bushette to secondhand over the first
double play
so once again the yankees
uncharacteristically
hit a lot of ground balls
and that cost them a double play right
there so here's a guy that needs to get
going with the bat and alejandro kirk
the catcher making his fifth start of
the season he's old for 13 so far
this ball is gonna go get up get out of
here
alejandro kirk with his first home run
of the season it's his first hit of the
season and the blue jays have a 2-1 lead
here's the hanging breaking ball and he
he doesn't miss it five home runs in the
second that's the most invisible
this is popped up and playable the shet
giving a long run guriel over and
bushette stays with it to make the catch
in fair territory point bow ran a long
way considering he was playing in the
shift up the middle would you want a one
pitch ground out or a three-pitch
strikeout
here's another drive to left field
gorilla hustling back he's got room he
makes the catch gashioka got jammed a
bit on that pitch pitch too fine
ground ball up the middle vizio from
near the bag and second throws in huh
here's bo buchet a right hand hitter to
lead it off against kluber
into the fly ball to right judge going
back this ball is carrying his ball is
gone
the ship
is on fire
and of course all of these young blue
jays played here in dunedin in their
path to the majors
that swing looks like he played here the
hands go forward the barrel stays back
that's how you get into in
side that baseball and drive at the
right field the wind aids that one out
of here judge homeward in the first
inning yankees don't have any other hit
that one's driven to center field and
deep turning and looking richard
sia a long home run to the right of dead
center a monster shot by judge and the
yankees now trail by one three to two
fastball right there you get one belt
high right there
ouch
well here's geo with second and third
and two men out now the 1-1 geo swings
and rips a line drive base it to left
field one run scores goriel's throw home
is way off line and two runs score
and the yankees take the lead a two-run
base it by gio ashela
pitch is swung on and chopped over the
mound to second flip the short one onto
first it is a double play you're gonna
give up home runs and uh you know he he
has done that but
you know he and ty and to me
look like they can be good again as this
ball gets by aaron judge
ambigio
and he's going to be in there with three
and now he's going to try to come home
and they have them in a run down
and he'll be tagged out by higashiyoka
and that will do it
and lines it and they get a shot at
first and there's rowdy toles and
another double play bruce has had a
rough start to his afternoon so lawwasic
has worked himself into a bases loaded
nobody out jammed so here is palacios
for something away off speed
grounded and grabbed by bruce he fires
home there's one and that's all they'll
get bases remain loaded for the lead off
man marcus simeon
bought into dirt that gets by here comes
tellez he's going to score and the blue
jays have tied it
that baldwin gets away from the gossioka
robbie tellez is one of the best base
runners on the team
popped up
shallow center field cutting in front is
gardner the runner at third kirk holds
grounded
to taurus
and against pachette
[Applause]
that one's grounded right to odor
swing and a miss
overpowered him two away
and simeon with a high fly ball
left field
we're going to the ninth all tied at
four
no run to hit no errors one man left
bro extended his hit streak to 11
straight
hit his third home run of the season
back in the third
breaking ball high in the air hicks
ranging back at the wall at the track
get out of here god a walk-off home run
for boba's [ __ ]
other home run went to right field
we mentioned the base hiss
it only took him 86 games to get to 50
career extra base hits add two more
today
and the blue jays are going to win the
series against the yankees
just like they did at yankee stadium
on a walk-off this time